hi there everyone  tickets are now on sale for marvel  studios eternal that's cool  new heroes  new dangers you can't protect any of  them  get ready for a journey thousands of  years in the making this is what the end  of the world looks like at least we have  front row seats  we're eternals  7 000 years we've protected humans from  the deviants  why didn't you guys help fight thanos or  any war all the other terrible things  throughout history  we were instructed not to interfere  until now  you hear that  eternal's assembled  hi  hello hey who's your gardener  this planet and these people have  changed all of us  when you love something  you protect it  for eternity  [Music]  marvel studios eternals what's your  superpower  you know that your babysitting  privileges are completely revoked  pg-13 get tickets now  you